The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: You'll
recall the last class was
a third of conceptual
models, this one dealing
with the organic shape of
nature and its replication
in patterning of cities.
We focused on a number
of examples, one of which
was the work of Patrick Geddes.
The second one was the work of
Ebenezer Howard and the garden
city movement.
The third was the work of
Clarence Stein in the United
States.
And then I did a short
run through of a piece
that I wrote last year
for a conference in Athens
on nature and the
city, in which I
argued that there was the most
dynamic thing about cities.
It is our human capacity to
learn and to adapt to change.
And I try to show
that in the life of 70
years of the Tennessee
Valley Authority,
the capacity to change
the perspective about what
nature is.
Nature is no static phenomenon.
It's a learning of
patterns as previously
identified in organic systems--
selectively.
So it requires the human brain.
And the Tennessee
Valley Authority
built 28 dams on the concept
that dams, that water power,
was more hygienic and would
be sufficient for creating
a new industrial zone in the
eight states of the Tennessee
Valley.
65% of the power now is
not generated by water.
The prediction of the
economic growth in this region
was very low.
Also, the capacity of the
water to produce enough energy
was low.
So what happened?
Coal became the substitute.
Coal led to strip mining, which
is as anti-natural phenomenon
as you can imagine.
The largest environmental
disaster in the United States
happened in the
coal spill from one
of the coal-generating
plants, and so on, and so on.
And we went through
an argument which
suggests that nature is
still a phenomenon which
is understood through the
process of the human brain.
There's no absolute
correctness of nature.
Biomorphism is a foolish
project by architects
who should understand a
much broader interpretation
of history and culture
than to select items
from array of natural forms.
It's purely a selection.
Yes, maybe-- we
have no measurement
that people are more
satisfied in a forest
than on Fifth
Avenue in New York.
We assume that to be true.
I suppose we could if
we got honest people
in a questionnaire.
But Marx was right,
that the establishment
of the first settlement set
up a duality between country
and city, which is going to
take a lot of time to resolve.
And it's still problematic.
What I've given you today are
some functional descriptive
theories borrowed mainly
from the social sciences.
I will go through each
of them with an example,
and discuss what the theory
is, and what it proposes,
what its weaknesses are.
This used to be a whole subject
for a whole semester in city
planning education.
It's hardly dealt with now.
Part of these are
classical series,
which no longer are
interesting to anybody.
The second page-- the first
page deals with the application
of one of these theories--
Hoyt's to Atlanta.
You can see the sector
theory in Atlanta,
indicating the location of
high-income white housing as
opposed to low-income housing,
following a model purported
by Homer Hoyt in 1935.
The next page deals
with examination
of two figures in Great
Britain, who lived
more or less at the same time--
John Ruskin, the
theorist of painting,
and Friedrich Engels, who we
will discuss more fully in two
weeks, in a week's
time, one of the origins
of the modern
Communist Manifesto.
And in 1845, at
the age of 25, he
wrote one of the greatest
books on urbanism ever written,
The Condition of the
Working Class in England,
which we'll discuss when
we talk about the origins
of the industrial city.
The next page is from
a diagram by Mel Weber
in a book called Urban Place
and Non-Place Urban Realm.
This was a set of studies,
which is published
in this book, [INAUDIBLE],, and
in another book called Cities
and Space, which deal with the
advent of the interpretation
of different systems
of communication
interacting in one place.
This is an oppositional position
to the conventional economic
models, or even physical
models, of interaction,
and an old model by a book
called A Communications Theory
of Urban Growth looking at the
measurement of intersections
in complementary
functions in spatial form.
And the last-- this
is the next page--
he's from economic
geography and represents
population potential diagrams.
And then next, we will finish
with a very recent piece
from The New York Times in which
a physicist solves the city.
This is hopefully what
we will finish with.
The question is, does it
really make any sense at all?
But we'll look at the work
of these people dealing
with models of complex
theory at the moment.
The first-- let's go
through this very quickly.
The first-- by the
way, these breakdowns
were created in this
class with Kevin Lynch
and follows them,
to some extent.
Cities are seen as unique
historical processes.
Each city is a unique
cumulative historical process.
A city can only be explained
by telling a story.
You cannot generalize
very much about cities.
What you can generalize
about is the way
of reading a city,
the idea you have
to learn the standard
way of looking at them.
So, for instance, Rasmussen
says two chief types
are distinguishable
among large cities--
the concentrated
and the scattered.
The former is the more
common on the continent.
It's clearly represented by the
big government seats of Paris,
and Vienna, and so on.
The second type is represented
by the English town, which now,
to many of us, seems ideal.
The question of what is
unique and what is generalized
is different in some
of these propositions,
even within this proposition
of the unique historic process.
You have a book, like Allan
Jacobs' book on streets, which,
by the way, doesn't include
the Nevsky Prospect, which
is one of the great
streets in the world.
It's only streets that
Allen Jacobs has visited.
In science, I don't know if
you can do experimentation
on the basis of only what you
have visited, but it's OK.
We are handicapped.
But the cities, the
streets, that he identities,
each is unique.
It gives measurements
of its width.
It gives dimensions of the
density around the street.
Whereas, Bill
Hillier's proposition,
which I'll discuss next Tuesday
amongst others, Space Syntax,
looks at streets
merely as linkages
in a topological
environment in which,
if you understand the
geometry of flows,
you can really make
generalizations about crime,
about social
behavior, and so on.
So there's often this tension
between what is conservative
unique to be
reproduced and what is
generalizable from
that phenomenon.
I was on a review last
January at Columbia
for a project that
students did in Palestine,
in a small town in
Palestine, sponsored
by RIFAC, an NGO which is trying
to establish Palestinian space.
And this was a project
for a small town which
had had no economic
base, but the students
were privileged
to study the town
and come up with suggestions
for a new economic base.
All the students took the
form of the city, that is,
the architecture-- and even
although it was only partially
still in use--
as the basis for
its reconstruction.
There was something about
its history, its presence,
which needed to be adapted.
So if some student, excuse me,
proposed to start a herbal drug
industry, they did it in an
adapted shelter already there.
If somebody wanted to start
a new business in vinegar
production in Palestine,
they took an old building,
and if it was not large enough,
they added a small fraction.
One student came along
and said the biggest
problem in this town
is garbage collection.
Garbage is not
properly collected,
and decays, and causes a very
unhealthy feeling in the town.
I'm proposing a new
garbage collection center
on the outskirts of the town.
And he designed a
mechanical instrument which
collected garbage effectively.
Everybody attacked the
student who did this project.
The historical sense
of conservation
and conservative appropriation
was so overwhelming
that the student who
proposed that a city may
be a place in which people
can learn, and can grow,
and change--
they do anyway-- there wasn't
much debate about the student's
proposition.
I kept quiet.
I should have said something.
But it was in New York, and
I felt like a provincial
from Boston.
So I had nothing to say.
But it was a very good
example of the postulation
that the uniqueness of
the historical process
can withstand notions
of change and growth.
The fascination with the
concept of learning from--
of being instructed
by what you see
has suggested the
word "reading."
Reading is used in
a number of cases.
It's used by the architect
Giancarlo De Carlo
in the ILAUD schools in Italy.
And so I took two
examples by two great men.
John Ruskin says, number
one, the vocation is seeing.
He talks about growing up in
a small village in England,
and there was nothing to do.
So he looked through the
windows to the house next door
and started learning how
to pattern the brickwork.
Now, this is something
that I suppose
not everybody should do.
I think we have more
intelligent things to do.
But he talks about seeing as
a constructive phenomenon,
as an intellectual activity,
which can be learned.
It's not automatic.
From a visual to the
social-political,
he's a professor of poetry
at Oxford University, one
of the most important
chairs in British academia,
and slowly turns his
attention to the fact
that there's a
distinction in Britain
between poverty and wealth.
His last books, Fors Clavigera,
is subtitled, Lessons
to the Working Men of England.
He takes students
on Sunday morning
to work and building
camps outside Oxford.
He sees that reading
is a combination
of aesthetic and moral values.
He says you have to
externalize the consequences
of your experience.
Therefore, he writes
these books and has
something to say about
reading and memory--
how memory is an important part
of the selective part of what
you understand.
Friedrich Engels comes to
Manchester as a teenager.
He's amazed at his
contact with reality.
First of all, you have
to understand that it's
important to observe reality.
Reality, in his case, was
the most degraded conditions
of housing and sewage that the
world had probably ever seen.
He says, you do it
with your body--
with eyes, ears, nose, and feet.
Number three, you do it
through the eyes of others.
He had a girlfriend who was
an illiterate Irish worker.
He walked through
the town with her
and would ask her questions.
I don't understand why the
window's always closed.
And she would say, the
windows are closed,
because the smell
is too whatever.
And then you communicate
what you've read,
and you go even further.
In his case, Manchester was
not a unique city for him.
He was reading a
phenomenon which
had universal implications.
It's interesting that
under Marx and Engels,
and as late as 1917, cities were
not considered as significant
in the Marxist dialogue.
They were larger issues at hand.
You had to change the structure
of society, and as a byproduct,
cities would change
automatically.
That doesn't work that way,
but so was the doctrine
of early Soviet Marxism.
And Engels himself changed.
There's a wonderful book
called Marx's General recently
published by an English
writer, which discusses Engel's
history in relation to Hegel.
Engels was in the army
in Berlin doing nothing.
So he attended a class in
religious philosophy taught
at the university.
At that time, religion was
a fundamental component
of the study of philosophy.
In his class was Kierkegaard,
Bakunin, the Russian anarchist.
I forget the names
of the others--
people who were there at the
same time questioning whether--
Hegel's work had just been
started to be published.
And Engels, again,
started adapting
the purest Marxist
doctrines to the reality
of the situations he was facing
in different parts of Europe
as he traveled.
The notion of historians who
claim the uniqueness of cities
is widespread.
Writing about
Venice, Mary McCarthy
says, there's nothing more
to be said about Venice,
and quotes Napoleon, Raskin,
Shelly, Proust all saying
the same things.
And says, I envy your
writing about Venice,
says the newcomer.
I pity you, says the old hand.
There's something a
little boring about saying
the same things about a city.
Walter Benjamin is a much
more lively character,
the German philosopher
who died in 1940,
but wrote essays on cities.
His essay on Naples is
particularly interesting.
Nevertheless, no city can fade
in the few hours of Sunday rest
more rapidly than Naples.
Here's a theory of the speed
at which the city changes
its form from working to rest.
I don't know of any
other person who's
ever observed the
phenomenon of the speed
that cities change from
one form to another.
He says, the well-known list of
the seven deadly sins located
pride in Genoa,
avarice in Florence,
voluptuousness in Venice, anger
in Bologna, greed in Milan,
envy in Rome, and
indolence in Naples.
He then goes on to talk
about what indolence means,
and porosity of
buildings, and builds
an incredible central
structure of this place.
What you do with it
is not important.
It's that a city is something
as particular as the gestures
that people make
with their hands.
He claims that the gestures that
people make with their hands,
with their nose, with their
eyes, with their breasts
in Naples is unique.
AUDIENCE: So?
JULIAN BEINART: So the
extraordinary thing
about Walter Benjamin is this
tension between this attitude
of finding the deep structural
explanation of cities
and being a Marxist himself.
As a Marxist, like
Engels, he would only
see Naples as a generalized
phenomenon of human experience.
He would look for
where poor people live,
and where the forces of
production were, and so on.
Instead, he's attracted by
this uniqueness phenomenon.
Everything is unique.
He writes about Paris
in similar ways.
Muchly is interesting
in Walter Benjamin,
over whom I'm a big fan.
So I shouldn't
criticize him too much.
Here's the architectural
critic, Norberg-Schulz,
the Norwegian critic, who
has made a-- who wrote a book
called Genius Loci,
which suggests, again,
that every town has a genius--
not every town.
He only selects a
couple, and then
tries to explain
what the genius is.
So in Prague, we
read the following.
"The fascination of Prague
resides, first of all,
in a strong sense of mystery."
Big deal, you know?
You have the feeling it
is possible to penetrate
ever deeper into things.
"Streetscapes, courtyards,
have an endless inside."
Now, that is maybe a profound
observation of Prague.
But as a theory, it
is terribly little.
It's very much-- in Khartoum--
he says, those who visit
Khartoum are immediately struck
by strong quality of place.
Well, am I not struck by a
strong quality of place if I
enter Léon?
Or is there a measurement of
the amount of quality that is
in Khartoum as opposed to Léon?
There is no attempt to
generalize about cities
whatsoever.
If science is about
generalization,
this is not anywhere
near scientific.
It's maybe what architects
do in reading or artists do,
which raises a very big
unresolved conflict in urbanism
between if it is a function of
art or a function of science.
Theories are especially seen
as functions, as estimates,
of knowledge in science
and in social science.
We have not resolved--
to propose, as we end up with
this piece by the physicists,
on what is important
to resolve in urbanism,
it may be that
the distinction is
between learning about
cities through art history.
Because if you look at
Prague, you think of looking
at Cézanne.
And although Rudolf Arnheim,
the gestalt psychologist, says,
that if you look at Cézanne, if
you'd follow the following path
with your eyes from red to
yellow and back to green,
and these forms all fit into a
scientific explanation of what
you see, that's bullshit.
We accept certain
truths through art.
The patterning of
music is studied
and available for
your understanding,
but it is an intuitive
experiential phenomenon.
Much of these explanations
are of that order.
They don't attempt to
compare the amount of mystery
in Rome versus the
amount of mystery
in Khartoum or in Prague.
Let's go on very quickly.
We've got half an hour.
There's a lot of
reading available
about each of these sectors.
So I will propose
that, if you're
interested in any of
these bodies of work,
either contact me, and
I'll give you more reading.
That's if you need
to do more reading.
There's enough in
this class already.
The next group of work is
number two, ecology of people.
The idea that
people, as a group,
behave in ways
which pattern a city
is most likely to be associated,
in the first instance,
with the work of the German
sociologists from 1900 to 1950.
I'll just briefly mention
them and talk a little bit
about what the
fundamental thinking
about the nature of cities was.
Max Weber in 1905--
the three are Max Weber,
Georg Simmel, S-I-M-M-E-L,
and Oswald Spengler.
For them, cities
were relatively new.
You must remember that
cities only grew at about 1%
per annum in Europe until
1930, when parts of England
grew ballistically at about 10%.
But it involved a
change in character.
For Weber, a city is essentially
a human settlement, which
could be called cosmopolitan.
It contains a variety
of life styles
and different sorts
of individuals
which have to coexist.
He argues that the best
way for them coexisting
is to establish ideal typical
conditions in which each state
of urban life most
neatly fulfills
the social capacities inherent
in any of the one groups.
So for him, an ideal city
would be the creation
of a phenomenon, which has a
large amount of distinction
in it, and the maintenance
of these social structures,
competing social structures,
the capacity to understand when
they change and when they don't.
He believes in the kind of
city that he was examining
in Germany at the time.
Georg Simmel noticed another
phenomenon of the emerging city
form.
And that is that it put pressure
on the individual existence.
The access of psychic
stimulation in a large city
would cause withdrawal.
This is a strange concept.
It maybe associates
itself with people
like Richard
Sennett, who's spoken
about the fall of public
man in similar ways.
That if in Simmel's case
it was the withdrawal
of people from the excessive
stimulation of the city,
in Richard Sennett's
case, it's the change
in the capacity of
people from maintaining
a state of publicness
to a preference
for a state of privacy.
I disagree with Sennett to some
extent about that observation.
As I'll deal with in
a subsequent class,
the notion of privacy
was foreign to people
until the middle
of the Middle Ages.
But Simmel talks of this.
"Whenever large numbers
of people live together,
there's a selfhood,
a human identity,
which tries to project
itself in the process.
Just as an example
of this phenomenon,
if you would wish to
withdraw in Manhattan
from the intense energy
that the city has produced,
why would you have glass on
the windows of your apartment?
There's been some
study of the amount
of glass and residential
accommodation, even
to the extent that--
what is the file,
old film, where
this man is in his
apartment and he's
hurt his leg so he can't move?
AUDIENCE: Rear Window.
JULIAN BEINART:
Rear Window, yes.
Who was the actor?
AUDIENCE: Jimmy Stewart.
JULIAN BEINART:
Jimmy Stewart, yeah.
Sorry, my memory
is falling apart.
The phenomenon that you
can use glass, as glass
gives you both the option of
withdrawing and being public.
It's an extraordinary idea.
That if you really-- if Simmel
were absolutely correct,
we would all live in
[INAUDIBLE],, or in gardens,
or anything
establishing ourselves
outside of the
turmoil of urbanism.
The glass apartment
block in Manhattan,
allowing people to see you
when you're ready to be seen,
but mostly available,
is a curious phenomenon.
Simmel might have had
something to say about it.
Oswald Spengler had a
typical negative view
of the future of the
emerging large city.
He said, very popularly
understood at the time,
that there was something
wrong, that it needed
to be curtailed in size,
that it's increasing
heterogeneity was a phenomenon
which was dangerous.
He believed that cities
would be destroyed.
And I don't know what
would replace them.
But he had this similar
idea to others in England,
that London would be dispersed
and into smaller communities,
largely in the rural
areas of England.
A complete nonsense of
an idea, but one which--
none of these people attempted
to understand the sociology
of an actual city.
They were generalists.
I'm reminded a little in
reading of this of a book, which
was recently published by Edward
Glaser at Harvard, called The--
AUDIENCE: Triumph of the City?
JULIAN BEINART: --Triumph
of the City, yes.
There isn't really time to
discuss this book at length.
But at some time in this
class, I would like to.
So ask me a question about
it when we have more time.
Its analysis is very much
in the old school manner.
But if Spengler proposes
that cities will disappear
because they are too
crude, and they've
deviated from decent
human principles,
Glaser sees the
future of interaction
in the modern city as
the essence of its being.
He proposes that a good city
would intensify into action,
because it's economically
important, and so on,
and so on, and so on.
He's not an architect.
So his penchant
for tall buildings,
residential buildings,
are indiscriminate of how
they are designed, and how
they are modulated, and so on.
It reminds me of what's
happening in China,
amongst other places.
The Chicago school were
a bunch of sociologists
who took a look at
the American city
for the first time analytically.
The concentric model of
Park, Burgess, and McKenzie
postulated a city, which is
much like a plant phenomenon,
that it increased and changed
as it expanded outwards.
That the city consisted
of rings, annular rings,
of social classes in
which the dynamic was
that you would move from
the center to the outwards.
And the inner ring is the
center, the central business
district.
Immediately surrounding
it is something
called the zone in transition.
Beyond that is the zone
of workingmen's houses.
of better residences.
Beyond that is
the commuter zone.
The zone of transition,
that immediate zone
around the central business
area, is of interest.
What distinguishes the American
city from the European Union
city in the grossest
sense is the American city
is city of immigration.
The European city is
quite the opposite.
It's only been open to
immigration recently,
and it's struggling like
hell to deal with it.
America's has gone
through a couple
of years, if not forever,
dealing with the problem
of immigration.
And the zone of transition
in the American city
was that undetermined
zone, before
the settled residential
population took
place, a zone in transition.
The obvious phenomenon
was that there's
a zone which had a more rapid
turnover than any other zone
in the city.
And this has actually
been the zone
which is been a
zone of immigration,
a zone of building of bypasses
past the central business area.
In fact, if anything,
it's a better flex zone
around the center of a city than
the park system of Adelaide,
which the organic model
is so enthused about.
There was a gentleman
called Homer Hoyt, who
during the Depression
years in Washington
did nothing else, without
a computer, calculated rent
payments in cities
in the United States,
particularly in Chicago.
He'd written a
book about Chicago,
from which he developed
an alternative model
to the concentric model.
That is, he claims that the
city is really patterned
on the basis of sectors.
Sectors allow people to move
towards higher income areas,
towards open space, towards
mountains, towards higher
natural phenomenon.
And therefore, you get
a division of people,
rather than occupying space
concentrically, occupying space
through wedges.
Now, if you look at
the diagram of Atlanta,
you'll see some justice
for his phenomenon.
It applies equally
well to Johannesburg.
And when I do a case study
with you of Johannesburg,
you will see how the sector
theory worked very well
up to a certain point
in the construction,
of the organization,
of the city.
In the case of Atlanta, you
have, as I've said before,
the phenomenon here
based on rent payments,
justifying the Hoyt model.
The Chicago school took place
in the great city of Chicago.
Chicago has been
called the Shock City
because of its rapid emergence.
Chicago didn't exist
in 1830, and in 1893,
at the time of the
Chicago World's Fair,
125th of all the world's
railroads passed Chicago.
It's the most rapidly--
and by virtue of its
rapid growth, which
wasn't accompanied by
government, or good government,
you have a phenomenon, which
I'll look into more carefully
when we discuss the
case of Chicago.
Chicago is the most phenomenal
19th century city of all.
And it's interesting
that Chicago
is the place where the
first academic study
of the social grouping of
cities should take place.
A lot of things happened for
the first time in Chicago.
Economics has paid a
serious but very scant
interest in location.
As Paul Krugman points
out, the new textbook
by Joseph Stiglitz at Harvard,
which is 1,000 pages in length,
has the word "city"
mentioned once
and the word "location"
mentioned once.
If you want to read about
it, read Krugman's views
on why economics has
not included location
as a serious input.
Read the pieces that
I've suggested you read.
There are two pieces
by Krugman explaining
why modern economics
after Marshall
managed very well on
optimization theories
without including the cost
of transportation or the cost
and benefits of location.
He claims there's been a
weakness in economic geography,
which has tried to measure up
to the purity of economics,
of modern economics,
and gives some
suggestions for maybe
a new post-real estate
study of location.
The classic allocation
models are still, number one,
at the regional level.
The work of von Thunen,
the German agronomist,
who argued that the
cost of transportation
was a phenomenon in
allocating land use.
He claims that, as I've said
before, around a center,
the spatial
distribution of crops
occurs according to
the yield per unit
area around a central town.
You end up with
dairy in the center,
orchards in the next ring,
grain in the next ring,
cattle in the next ring,
and forestry furthest
from the center.
This is not only a
function of land values,
but a function of the
cost of transporting goods
to the center.
Southern Germany, where von
Thunen, and Christaller,
and people like that,
economic geographers' work
was essentially flat.
And with population growth
occurring at a very low rate,
the notion of a single-centered
city or a distributed pattern
of cities at regular
intervals was appropriate.
Christaller based his
economic geography on the idea
that they were central
places, and you
can see this phenomenon
in Northern Italy today.
If you move eastward from Milan,
30 miles from Milan is Brescia.
30 miles from Brescia is Verona.
Vicenza is 30 miles from Verona.
Pádova is 30 miles, and Venice
at the end of this horizontal
east-west axis.
If you go from
Milano to Bologna,
you have 30 miles to Pavia,
then 30 miles to Parma,
30 miles to Reggio,
30 miles to Moderna,
and 30 miles to Bologna.
On the axis from Bologna in
the big triangle to Venice,
[INAUDIBLE] Ferrara, which is
about 30 miles from Bologna,
and then historical
land patterns
didn't allow this
phenomenon to take place.
There was a big exhibition
in Italy entitled,
"The Culture of 999 Cities."
What is interesting about
Christaller's interpretation
for contemporary times is
that a place like Moderna
produces the headquarters
of Lamborghini, Ferrari,
and Maserati and still is a
relatively small population
center.
If you go to
Cortona, near Arezzo,
it has a bunch of things.
Almost every small
town has a center
and a condition of uniqueness.
The genius of the
Italian landscape
is in not developing--
well, so they argue.
They haven't developed
large cities.
Milano is not a village,
but the Italians
are free to interpret
things very freely.
But the genius of being able to
be small, and yet to be unique,
and to--
I was asked to come
to Ferrara once,
because they started a
new school of architecture
run by a friend of mine.
And the city was going
to give them a building,
and they wanted this
small group of people
to choose the building.
They took us to
a building, which
they had given to
the man who developed
the first electronic
system for the movies,
and it made a film which was
very popular at the time,
possible prior to all
of this computer stuff.
There was a sense in
this town that there
was an appreciation of its
capacity to be located locally.
You bought food from
the shop on the corner,
but yet it had an
international aspiration.
And put together,
all of these places
constituted the
Italian urban culture.
It's a strange phenomenon,
but it's the phenomenon
which is worth noticing.
And it's a phenomenon
which organizes
the city and the country
in a different way
than the very large city and the
very large spatial hinterland.
It's worth talking about as
we develop this class a bit
further, but it emanates
from Christaller's work--
C-H-R-I-S-T-A-L-L-E-R.
The third application of
the classical economic model
is in the distribution of
activities in the center,
in the central city itself.
Here you will have
the phenomenon,
which seems very crude
still at the moment,
that they are two variables.
The one is the amount
of rent, the money
you want to pay in
rent at one access,
and another axis which
says the distance that you
can be from the center.
The argument being, that in the
center, you pay higher rates,
and the further out you
go, the lower rent you pay.
But you have to pay the
increased transportation costs.
So that balance will
produce suburban and then
exurban locations,
depending on the improvement
of the transportation
system outwards.
That you'll get
movements of people
as they classically make
more income from the center
outwards.
And this is the
working class people
in this graph come in the former
curve in the center, where they
balance minimal costs
of transportation
and public transportation
with low, medium rents,
and so on, and so on.
[INAUDIBLE] is here at MIT and
the father of regional science.
He's one of the
formulators of this theory.
Alonso at Harvard
did versions of it--
Wingo, [INAUDIBLE] and others.
Let me just say a few words
about the others in this list.
There have been attempts to
modulate the former cities
by analogies to physics,
population potential being
the--
let me get this correct.
I often make a mistake with--
well, forget about it.
We haven't got time to go
into the great difference
between the population
potential moral, gravity
models, communications,
networks, and topology.
I should add to that
more current work
in fractal and
chaos theory, which
if you want to read about
fractals, read [INAUDIBLE]..
But I estimate
these as having less
of a life in determining current
practice in urbanism than any
of the others.
They're somewhat academic.
Gravity models, Forester's
urban systems, all of these form
an attempt to use
notions of proximity,
not notions of income, to
locate shopping centers,
to make modifications
to the American city.
The question of decisions,
linked decisions,
again, here we have to
look at the work of people
like Forester, who claims that--
we'll see the same phenomenon
in the work of John [INAUDIBLE]
on Tuesday.
John [INAUDIBLE] claim is
that the built world is really
the outcome of
agreements that are
made between different people.
There is no city but
the one that rests on
made agreements, and
tries to determine
from made agreements what could
be the form of a city which
takes that into account.
Jay Forester argues that social
systems are currently complex,
and single answers are not
predictable or should not
be expected.
Urban systems are
based on information
about the important decisions
that largely businessmen
make in the American city.
He hasn't asked
anybody or studied
data of any significance.
He comes to simplistic
resolutions,
that the more the economy
grows, the more poor people
you will have, and
things of this kind.
And I'm not doing him
justice in one sentence.
Then the arena of conflict,
which is really quite
an interesting phenomenon.
Much of the models
that I've gone through
have assumed that the city
is composed of benign people
making benign agreements
amongst each other.
Park and Burgess's model
of concentric circles
means that it all, like
a plant, takes place
without the plant having any
items of conflict or conflict
as a phenomenon.
Whereas, in fact,
for many centuries,
the resolution of conflicts
through the building of walls
was a fundamental
aspect of city form.
[INAUDIBLE],, at the end
of the 17th century,
or the beginning of
the 18th century,
could design a town which
could not be penetrated.
So his reputation was--
Blondell taught fortification
to architecture students
at the academy in Paris.
The people who have
taken up conflict
really exist on the left.
There's David Gordon, who
explains American suburbia
by the movement of
bosses to get away
from workers in labor strife.
You get Manual Castells in
his pre-communication theory
mode, who is a young
Spanish Marxist who
wrote something called The
Wild City, in which he claims
that suburbanisation is the
function of surplus commodities
rather than of any
other form of economy.
David Harvey, arguing
that it's very difficult
to produce social
equity under capitalism,
because there will
always be obstacles
in the way of maximizing
return on capital.
Lefebvre, the French sociologist
who ran a journal called
[FRENCH]--
I was the editor
of [NON-ENGLISH],,
Space and Society, which was--
I was part editor, following
Lefebvre's example.
All of these are looking at
the way in which conflict
can be assumed and
resolved as part
of the real existence of a city.
Giancarlo De Carlo,
Italian architect,
used to argue that one
of the functions of--
one of the ways of
displaying conflict
was to allow
architecture to build
in its appropriate
fashion, but to depict
the elements of conflict
that are available,
and to heighten the sense
of conflicts in a city,
but also to make it possible,
in a kind of anarchic sense,
for that city's
resolutions to be
made within a framework
of understood conflict--
resolvable conflict,
not revolution.
So these attempts
at plans sometimes
manifest this, or at least.
If you look at the
workers' housing in Terni,
for instance, you can see
elements of this proposition,
but it's very vague,
and very generalized,
and not really a
powerful theory.
The Marxists have
not produced cities
which have externalized the
conflict notions which they
examined in the [INAUDIBLE].
Their cities are much like
any city in the world.
And Chinese Marxism
is certainly not
producing very much
from which we can
learn about new city growth.
So this particular
theory is waiting too.
Most of these theories--
let me just end off at
once with this piece
I gave you on the physics of--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JULIAN BEINART: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: The work
of [INAUDIBLE]??
JULIAN BEINART: Yes.
Do you know his work?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JULIAN BEINART: What
do you think of it?
AUDIENCE: I think it brings
in an interesting perspective
of all these findings on the
efficiency of [INAUDIBLE]
innovation of investment
versus how the population grows
at the same time the per
capita wealth it generates.
But it seems to be a
bit reductionist to me.
JULIAN BEINART: You
know, it starts--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
universal model.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah,
it starts separating out
what optimizes the
functioning of a city in terms
of transportation,
land use, crime,
and so on, which are important
components to understand.
But he doesn't accept the
city as an environment which
has speciality, or experience,
or any of the things
that art history--
I'm beginning to think more
and more, that in order
to understand urbanism, you
need to study art history
and perhaps forget
about all of this stuff.
But we all know that
every city is unique.
That's all we talk about
when we talk about cities.
But focusing on those
differences misses the point.
Sure, there are differences.
But different from what?
We found the what.
There's an arrogance
about the security
of physics as applied to complex
phenomena, such as a city.
It may be that this is a
new generation of thinking.
I mean, they're doing it
at Oxford, and Santa Fe,
and there are more and more
groups of complex theorists
emerging.
I have my doubts.
I'll be too old to see
any of this anyway.
So I leave it to you.
On Tuesday, we will look
at, for the last time,
in Part 1 of the subject,
at four or five theories
of architects, contemporary
architects, who
are recently
deceased architects,
who've made attempts, such as
Space Syntax, so on, and so on.
And then start from scratch
with the Industrial Revolution
and see what we can learn by
looking carefully at phenomena.